[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous amène à la
découverte de Guy en cour une ville
ivelinoise qui fait partie de la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline alors cette
ville elle accueille près de 30000
habitants 900 entreprises elle abrite
également des monuments historiques des
lieux culturel et des espaces forestiers
et naturels une ville où il fait bon
vivre allez c'est parti on va la
[Musique]
découvrir premier stop le golf national
avec plus de 120 hectares ce cite est
l'équipement phare de la Fédération
Française de Golf il se compose de trois
parcours celui de l'Albatros pour les
championnats l'aigle pour les amateurs
et l'Oiselet le parcours d'entraînement
c'est Christophe Sifredi golfeur et
employé du site qui nous emmène faire un
[Musique]
tour est sur le trou 1 et le trou 2 de
l'Albatros deux trous signature du Golf
National avec des pièces d'eau et des
butes sur les bords des trous sont
vraiment deux éléments qui caractérisent
le parcours du Golf
[Musique]
National
les buts naturels qu'on trouve sur les
côtés des trous permettent de faire des
gradins un petit peu comme dans un stade
de rugby ou de foot pour permettre aux
gens d'être en escalier les uns devant
les autres et de gagner rapidement de la
hauteur en reculant un petit peu s'il
veulent voir plus loin devant eux
c'était vraiment un succès pendant la
rider Cup mettre beaucoup de gens dans
les buts sur les
[Musique]
côtés rider Cup France et bientôt les
Jeux Olympiques le Golf National
accueille de nombreux événements des
espaces aménagés sont donc essentiels
pour l'accueil des grands événements
tout le Golf National tout le parcours
de l'Albatros est entouré de chemins en
goudron qui permettent même au plus gros
camion de desservir toutes les zones du
parcours et de pouvoir accéder
rapidement allez direction le practice
pour frapper quelques
vales
alors Régine aujourd'hui on va commencer
avec un fer neu qui est un des clubs les
plus faciles à taper qui permet de lever
facilement la balle d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok
[Musique]
désormais petit tour à la batterie de
Bouvier ce pôle musique construit au 19e
siècle était à l'origine une base
militaire Marjorie pardailler galabrin
est en charge du service de la culture
et de l'événementiel à la mairie de Guy
encour elle nous présente C lii
emblématique de la ville on y retrouve
l'école municipale de musique de danse
pour lequel on propose à nos Guillant
courtois de pratiquer nombre
d'instruments avec nos 30 professeurs de
musique et il est rattaché l'udito notre
salle qui contient jusque 200 places
pour laquelle on met en œuvre une saison
culturel en lien avec le projet
d'établissement de l'école municipale et
nous avons aussi des studios
d'enregistrement et de répétition ainsi
qu'une magnifique salle debout qui va
jusqu'à 500 places et où propose une
programmation variée musicale musique
actuelle et vous avez déjà reçu des
têtes d'affiches des stars de renom oui
effectivement nous avons par exemple
reçu zigy Marley nous avons reçu caliie
nous avons reçu Deluxe nous avons reçu
thérapie taxi il y a 1 an on avait dans
notre partie de
Résidence Pierre Demar qui préparait
donc son album et qu'on a tant entendu
autour de nos festivals d'été voilà
c'est des
exemples et juste derrière nous Orianne
Lacaille une artiste en résidence est
actuellement en train de s'entraîner
avec son groupe elle incarne le
métissage musical entre la Réunion et la
France
[Musique]
métropolitaine
et comme on dit après l'effort le
réconfort j'ai bien marché mais
maintenant je vais bien manger j'ai
réservé une table au restaurant La
chalos qui propose une cuisine du
Sud-Ouest de la France alors apparemment
il y a de super bons avis donc c'est
parti bonjour Mame bonjour deux couverts
de couverts je vous enprie
installez-vous
allez-y alors je vous mets la petite
rillette doigt pour vous souhaiter la
bienvenue c'est gentil alors la Chalosse
tout le monde m'en parle est-ce que vous
pouvez m'en faire une petite
présentation la chalos c'est une partie
du territoire adland donc finalement
quand on vient ici on voyage exactement
en fait ici il faut se dire que on n
plus à Paris on est dans le Sud-Ouest et
donc c'est pour ça que c'est c'est à
nous de diriger les gens vers lesim leur
faire connaître les traditions de ma
région puisque moi je suis native de
labas quelles sont les spécialités que
vous pouvez nous proposer aujourd'hui
alors comme plat traditionnel déjà je
vais vous faire découvrir notre FO gras
qui est fait ici et qui arrive de ma
région crue et on le travaille vraiment
ici en cuisine la préparation la
confection de A à Z voilà et ensuite je
vais vous faire goûter le parmentier de
confit de canard alors ça c'est
délicieux c'est très chaud ça vous
réchauffe de l'intérieur c'est du confit
de canard que l'on défait que l'on
éignette on le mélange avec des
échalotes caramélisées de la vraie purée
maison de la crème et du PARM de la
crème et de l'eau soirati et en dessert
il y a la jolie landaise c'est un
dessert landais que j'ai revisité donc
c'est croustill avec des pommes chaudes
pas de chocolat pas de Chantilly juste
que du naturel comme la plupart des
choses ici
[Musique]
d'ailleurs
super
[Musique]
bon et voilà c'est ainsi que se termine
notre visite à guillencour alors moi mon
passage préféré c'était au Golf National
puisque c'était une première pour moi
mais au-delà de ça guillencour c'est une
ville où il fait bon vivre qui est
d'ailleurs idéal pour une vie de famille
j'espère que vous avez apprécié ce petit
ip et je vous dis à bientôt pour de
prochaines
découvertes